gauchy richard vanoc ladies and
gentlemen dear friends i am very disappointed with
the result that concluded our debate
this enlargement five years ago by
taking up my post
i told parliament that for the next
five years for the five
years  of my mandate there would be
no further enlargements this had
caused a lot of disappointment in the
western balkans region
but it turned out obviously what
was foreseeable against none is
again
no new state would be able to
fulfill the  criteria can become mans
but what we attended tonight
was quite different because
it was not a question
of whether or not north macedonia
and albania were ready  to join
the european union it was a question of saying
whether or not they could become
we are candidates candidates with
whom we would have started
negotiations
the european concert whose majority
would have liked  say it but there
were some member states that
were not yet ready it's a
big historical mistake
a heavy historical slate and
I hope she can and moving
years so that she does not fit
into putting them in  the same time the
collective memory as having remained
from a historic error
we discussed today the
financial framework from this coming year very
few new elements
I reminded the Board that they had
an obligation the members of the
European Council to quickly conclude this debate
if we wait until the end of next year
we would lose other
years during which researchers
cannot search
young people will not be able to take part in
the Erasmus program when it is one
of the most beautiful  successes of the european union
the council I am sure has a lot on
its plate to come to
an agreement on the budget that the commission
has proposed because it is a
proposal  know who combines the
policies that were and the new
policies that must begin
this will have been the last
european council of the un and
myself according to the berbers ification by the way it
was the 148th european council which
i attended
you  will see that I would have been the only one to be
able to say that he attended there almost
150 concerts at the pm I would like at the
end of the round to thank donald for his
friendship and his complicity the for the
leadership that we knew that to
manage I  would like to thank you
because some of you my
companion for centuries others
on the most recent period of my life
that I learned a lot from you I
followed with interest your writings and your
reports you have  also I believe
that large deserved of Europe
I remain very proud until the end of my
life to have been able to serve
[Applause]
match 2 froyo